el pueblo griego nuevamente llamado a
las urnas Y con estas elecciones
legislativas las segundas en cinco
semanas el Primer Ministro saliente
kiriacos aspira a la mayoría absoluta
para gobernar sin coalición su gran
promesa Un gobierno estable
en tiempos de incertidumbre el país
necesita una cierta gestión necesita un
gobierno que no dependa de mayorías
frágiles que no dependa de lobbies que
no dependa del equilibrio de poderes
a la cabeza de la lista de aquellos con
los que el conservador no quiere
compartir el poder está la figura de la
izquierda radical europea Alexis cifras
a pesar de la marca derrota que sufrió
en las primeras elecciones del 21 de
mayo el líder del partido sirisa ha
dicho que luchará hasta el último
segundo
tenemos dos planes diferentes dos puntos
de vista diferentes dos visiones
diferentes para Grecia nuestra Visión Es
la de una sociedad de un país
democrático y justos menos desigualdades
un país y una economía donde la riqueza
aumente y se distribuya equitativamente
entre los ciudadanos
ya obtuvo una amplia Victoria el 21 de
mayo con más del 40% de los votos pero
para alcanzar esta vez su objetivo de
mayoría absoluta Apuesta por un sistema
de votación diferente el partido ganador
recibirá una cuota de hasta 50 escaños
en los últimos días el líder derechista
ha intentado movilizar a las multitudes
para convencer a la gente que podría
estar desanimada de acudir a unas nuevas
elecciones la campaña electoral También
estuvo marcada por el hundimiento de un
pesquero el 14 de junio con hasta 750
personas a bordo según algunos
supervivientes esta tragedia sigue
planteando muchos interrogantes tanto
sobre las circunstancias en las que se
produjo como sobre la controvertida
política migratoria de